[Music]
even more disastrous behavior from new
york city officials get this New York
City's failed health commissioner
reportedly blew off New York Police
Department requests for surgical masks
and March saying I don't give two rats
asses about your cops what pretty
despicable here with reaction former New
York City Mayor Rudy Giuliani the cops
were asking for the masks because they
were getting sick mr. mayor how does
this guy still have a job tonight it's a
woman and only because she reflects the
mayor's attitude if there's nobody in
this city I mean certainly no police
officer that wouldn't expect that that's
de Blasio's attitude he's meant at odds
with the police department from the day
he came into office they turned his back
on him because of some of the things
that happened during the murder of
Detective Liu and Ramos he's never
really spoken up for them he wasn't
there for them now and trying to get
them to help and support they did over
5,000 are sick 40-plus have died already
or near death look if you don't
understand as a mayor how to get the
support of your Police Department you
should resign it's the most important
agency that you have it's the one that
keeps people alive and here the mayor of
New York City you get a blessing from
God because you've got the best Police
Department in the world I mean I had I
had a reformer two-bit and I had three
great commissioners but most of all I
had an unbelievable group of forty
thousand police officers about 99.9% of
whom are the best in the country and the
world so if you if you turn them off
you're not meant to be mayor should be
something else I don't know maybe you
know mayor mayor where you went on your
honeymoon de Blasio you know the plaza
didn't buy the 10,000 ventilators that
his own health force said he'd need the
500 he had he auctioned offices we don't
know who to and then he was saying March
2nd through 5th go out on the town here
are my recommendations March 10th he was
saying it's still the risk is very low
okay a lot of people got it wrong and
left it's a disaster it's a distance oh
no no he got it wrong by two or three
more weeks than anybody else I mean
because
basically he doesn't go to work I mean
the guy comes in late well-known story
doesn't really pay attention gets away
with it because the New York Times
protects them the post covers it
somewhat but they actually don't cover
it the way they should
he's been a disaster of a mayor I have a
radio show now on a special on
coronavirus and I've asked I've
challenged people to defend him I said
somebody called me up and defend him I
can't find a Democrat in this city that
defends him Shawn I can't have my
Democratic friends who are angry at me
for supporting Trump and representing
Trump I'll say to them what about the
Blasio and they'll say let's talk about
something else nobody defends him he has
no one I've never seen this before and
it tells you something that you should
understand who you select for major
public offices is a matter of life and
death and when you select an incompetent
or people die now this health
commissioner I haven't seen her for this
entire pandemic my health commissioner
during West Nile virus and anthrax and
9/11 was all over the place this is the
first appearance condemning that lease
and then széchenyi sayonara gone and
then they sent they sent these Kohi
patients of the nursing homes agreed
gone mr. mayor
wish you was still mayor thank you